hey everybody here is all of destiny
twos cutscenes for the main story
fair warning it will come across as
disjointed because it is just all the
cutscenes there's a lot of dialogue
happening during gameplay so if you want
to be able to experience the full story
you should play the game yourself if you
liked the video please give us a sub and
a like it really helps us out
[Laughter]
[Music]
I never knew you in life your first life
anyway you died on a battlefield long
before my time something special brought
us together they called it the traveler
and when it arrived it changed your
world forever it was a golden age and
for centuries humanity thrived
until it different an ancient enemy
pursued the traveler across the universe
humanity faced extinction
but the traveler made a choice it
sacrificed destroyed its ancient enemy
and brought life to the ghosts
I am a ghost more importantly I'm your
ghost and you are one of the travelers
chosen
you are a garden
[Music]
this is your destiny
[Music]
at Quora
if you tell me this is a brothel joke
well it kills me to say it but I would
be really impressed impressing you Kaede
is the easiest thing I'll do all day
let's get serious people Zavala this is
my serious face can't you tell I Cora
what have you got someone or something
has sabotaged the skyline defense
systems and comms have been spotty for
the last few hours every sensor beyond
the wall was come dark hmm maybe it's
just the storm
maybe it's what are the set feet stones
[Music]
nothing that's good right
no I mean they're not there there are no
satellites
[Music]
battle stations
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
repeat Tao approach this is City Hawk
723 anyone home
no response on any channels even the
emergency frequencies what is going on
back there remember when I told you that
you fly too fast
forget I said that fly fast
[Music]
Zavala picked up that Guardian you never
shut up about
hold on back there
[Music]
come on the guy
do something
[Music]
alright Guardian time to check up where
dirt
how do we come back from this
welcome to a world without light
Guardian something's wrong
do not look at me creature
a participant covering the eyes walls
shall not break is merely forgotten the
allow me to reacquaint you
your kind ever deserves
right
this mine
[Music]
no look somebody left a perfectly good
guardian lying around things must be
worse than I thought and that's our cue
time to go people as far away from here
as possible
[Music]
Falcon belongs to you the names
Hawthorne and this is Luis Andres pilot
we got what about you fit to fly
probably gonna need one of these - time
to make yourself useful Guardian
all right people and spin them up got a
long way ahead of us
[Music]
- you see traveler all that I have done
grease me with your light take your
place at the center of my Empire see me
Gardens Dominus
the city is secured those who fled are
being hunted and those foolish enough to
remain have been executed victory as
with all things is yours to claim this
victory is as much yours as my old
friend all that remains is the
completion of the cage around this great
machine then we may begin the extraction
of its power and put it to its rightful
use they call the traveler
I would contend that other civilizations
may be more precise in their naming its
functions can be controlled and exported
as we have so clearly proven yet they
believe it to be a God
[Music]
Dominus
goal we have spent our lives you will
know
working to reshape our society reforge
our people rebuild an empire nearly
destroyed by calluses greed and
corruption there is nothing in this
universe greater than you the red Legion
will have that machine's power you will
be called Emperor
what more would the Dominus have I would
have words with my guest
[Music]
coming up on the European dead zone
gonna be our new home robot look do you
recognize it that's where we're supposed
to go nothing they call it the shard of
the traveler I call it not a place you
want to go poking around
[Music]
I'm sure you want to do this that shard
is the reason this place is called a
dead zone we have to it's a sign
yeah a sign that says dead though
[Music]
this is why we were live here
I haven't been as close to the travelers
light-sensitive do you feel it
hold on
[Music]
do you feel it the light is back we're
back
I shaft guardian
don't get cocky now that you've got your
powers back the EDC is rough especially
around the old town
just remember refugees from the city
have it a lot rougher
you want to help them find Deborah McKay
[Music]
[Music]
you made it looks like Lewis owes me
money all right let's see if this works
now if I read the manual right
[Music]
there's an incoming beacon
Goddard's the city is lost if there is
any light left in the system with rally
on titan be brave the father is alive if
we leave now weak you are not going to
Titan we've got refugees coming in the
red Legion on one side the Fallen on the
other but we have our powers back and if
we're going to retake the city city is
gone
we will be back and we won't be alone
you'll know where to find me
[Music]
it would save us both a lot of time if
you would just kill me for one who calls
himself speaker you'll have remarkably
little to say we've learned that one of
your Guardians has reconnected to the
light you say you have no power of the
traveler yet this helped me understand
speaker the light lives in all places in
all things you can block it even try to
trap it but the light will find its way
and the traveler will protect itself
[Music]
yes I've studied it the world has
touched its power of a life and death we
are not so different your traveler and I
you are nothing like the traveler
nothing you think you have power control
I know your kind you started
[Music]
myself and leave this system in ashes
only those the traveler chooses will be
rewarding the light yes
inside all
this is why I have claimed your planet
and one still
the travel of Easton and our fleet
guardianship seven-to-three is one
approach we received your beacon and
we're ready to join the fight
ngati chupa this is above
it's too late the hive have overrun ten
I was wrong to bring us here
I didn't dare believe if the light can
find its way back to you
the perhaps there is hope for us all
our numbers will continue to dwindle we
can no longer protect ourselves much
less the survivors
without the light but we even the
guardians anymore commander
[Music]
we won't last long with dead generators
wave energy converters power this
station but thanks to the hive they're
in need of attention we can take care of
it yes I believe you can
[Music]
they call it the Almighty
the crown jewel of the red Legion and
life's work of their leader
Dominus guhl guhl has subjugated
hundreds of worlds those that resisted
no longer exist
you see the almighty uh nyle eight stars
[Music]
[Music]
nothing and no one survives Gauls
ambition what he wants is the traveler
and it's light
as for the almighty it's now pointed at
our son
in short sir the war is over
and we've lost
we built our home under the protection
of the traveler when our enemies
attacked we built a wall that stood for
centuries but now walls mean nothing
this enemy has taken our home taken our
light and now they threaten our very
existence we're going all in on this
almighty how long before the fleet's
combat-ready Zavala wait if we wait we
die but if we attack together we can
take back our home our light our hope or
we die trying
now I need my fire team
I need my Korra and decayed
[Music]
so much for nothing being here let's get
to high ground so I can pin down Kate's
location quick hurry come on I don't
know how long this portals gonna stick
Kate what have you dropped us off look
look long story it may look like I don't
know what I'm doing but I do get maybe
nothing it doesn't matter
killing the power source at the origin
point should break the loop and get me
out of the portal system have you got
that say you've got it see something
fine I'll say it we got it Kate now how
did you put my [ __ ] sock did you not
hear what I just said I'm guessing this
is why they don't like him leaving the
tower
hey downtown so it's true
the light found its way back to you
not that I'm jealous are nothing but
they get easy out there really yeah
you're making me look bad
what may we ask were you going to do
with the vex teleporter
get up close and personal with go put a
bullet in his head then maybe eat a
sandwich gotta work out a few kinks
first fun fact about the vets tech that
is intuitive as you think Kade you can't
do this alone
hell I can't even if you manage to kill
God when the red leader leave a system
defeat or victory they leave nothing
behind
the Cabal are bad guys who do bad things
yes I get it I'm sorry but I do not
think you do
the Cabal literally sweep nothing behind
they have a weapon that can destroy a
star and it is pointed directly at our
Sun hey hey hey easy easy you're gonna
blow a poll the father has a plan he
needs you Caden
yes well Zavala always says he has a
plan but sometimes he just wait Zavala
said he needs me as in you heard those
exact words coming out as of Allah's
mouth yes we did
please tell me you recorded it well the
Nikora at least Eric actually the father
lost her after the city fell we don't
know where she is
aiyyo aiyyo is it's where she'd go to
look for answers
hey thanks Bo you
of all the places I've been in all the
years since my rebirth this is where I
returned the last place the traveler
touched
I came for answers I stand here still
with nothing on Quora zabala
is forming a resistance if he believes
what good is a resistance when you are
the only one who would survive I believe
this goal creature knows the traveler
blessed this site I believe he sent his
legion to find something they could
never possibly understand and I believe
they will continue to desecrate all we
hold sacred save this place Guardian do
not squander this second chance
[Music]
tell me again speaker
what makes your guardians worthy of the
light what is the price of such power
and immortality the devotion
self-sacrifice death death explain
devotion inspires bravery bravery
inspires sacrifice sacrifice leads to
death so feel free to kill yourself
devotion sacrifice I was born about
caste
around as his custom with the Cabal
I was cast aside and left for dead
I was taking him by an old scholar
himself disgraced the soul he means
something they deal upon they raised me
taught me trained me and in return I
would become a Fievel for his revenge
against an empire that failed him that
failed itself rejection ridicule torment
it made me stronger I gave everything to
win not just acceptance but glory
beneath my pass sticker is the face of
devotion and sacrifice I will not take
the light by force to do so would be to
admit failure and I never fail
now you see what I will be chosen I see
now
I see you all that you have done
our operational Megerian who was a
successful once the cage is complete we
will have everything we need to begin
the process of extracting the light
Dominus
everything we've worked for is here for
the taking all that remains is your word
no this is not the way old friend
but it is the way the only way
[Music]
so really what you're saying is we're
damned if we do damned if we don't
on the contrary now that we are together
again we just might stand a chance the
fact is if we destroy that weapon we
will ignite a chain reaction that could
send our son into what's well at least
we have each other indeed we all know
what needs to be done the traveler must
be freed I'm thinking the three of us is
a big fat pile of explosives can get the
job done look I still have that vex
teleporter it's got a limited range so
we'll have to get a little too close for
comfort then we get inside the city
wolves for it to be effective but
without the light and outright assault
on the wall is doomed to fail we could
there will be no coming back
it's worth it how do we get in
you know the city wall is kind of like
this barn
plenty of places to slip in unseen so
long as you know how
[Music]
you sure you're not one of my hunters
not really into capes clearly last
poncho you need to get your team into
the city without raising any alarms my
people and I can help you do that we
also happen to be pretty good at
shooting bad guys Hawthorne it's one
thing for us to put our lives on the
line but this doesn't have to be your
fight you're not a a guardian you think
you've cornered the market on sacrifice
you forget that we've had to survive
without the light all our lives once
upon a time that big white ball in the
sky was there for all of us I think it's
about time we return the favor
guardians are not that's great speech at
all but let's not forget about the whole
supernova and complete annihilation
thingy if we can't destroy the almighty
we'll have to disable its weapon and
that means getting a certain Guardian on
board we'll need a good disguise if
we're going to fly bright through a
cabal Armada
it's a cabal ship you need there's a
base nearby full of them
but it won't be easy sneaking in we've
done sneaky if there's one thing I've
learned from Kade it's the value of a
grand entrance this is great anyone want
a hug hugs no
No
[Music]
our plan relies on you destroy the all
my T's weapons and the threat to our
world while you're doing that we'll get
in position for the final run on the
city
time for God's last days
Savalas troops are already getting into
position around the city but they can't
attack her til we shut this thing down
so ready when you are partners
[Music]
yeah there's a good job colonel what's
that now seven in a row yeah who needs
the light when you got a fine feathered
friend by your side am i right am i
right or am i right all right okay yeah
that's the rally point we're all set up
to teleporter Zavala and a chorus should
get there marched by now
Zavala we're in position as are we at
kora ready when you are
fire in the hole
[Music]
what's with you Guardians falling down
all the time please Kate
if you sticking to the plan
[Music]
he's right where he needs to be now we
just got to get you and I Cora up there
with him
[Music]
well this changes things I'll work on
this you need to get moving hi Cora Kade
is in place in I'm on route good luck
darling
[Music]
cool the enemy attacks the city and the
old my teen is lost lost explain
yourself
laid waste by the very same Guardian
that somehow managed to reclaim its
power and has been humiliating our
forces throughout this cursing system
you would know this if you hadn't been
wasting your time communing with a
machine and the creature who claims to
speak to tear your tone console my tone
we will fail in our mission to secure
his mouth and deliver our people for the
first time in the glorious history of
the red region fail because of you and
your preoccupations look at your
traveler Dominus
the cage is complete the time is now
claim what is rightfully yours and take
this power speaker what more does the
traveler want of me go I speak for the
traveler
I never said it spoke to me
[Music]
this fixation is over you have already
been chosen not by some inert machine
but by me I chose you the day I found
you remember who you are what you are
you are come on come on we for nothing
you will get to light do what you swore
and give me the Vengeance you promised
look at me student
friend
the traveler what's happening to it
Zavala we're back in
using your traveler that's it they say
once more
look upon me Dominus at the ready
children Annihilator of sons razor of a
thousand words slanted
[Applause]
and I have become legend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the light lives in all places in all
things you can block it even try to trap
it
the light will find its way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you